I first discovered you as a lot of
people did watching Key and Peele
sketches and I would watch these
sketches and I would say okay these are
these are so well written these are such
great ideas these are such perfect
sketches and these two guys are playing
them perfectly and it made me so happy
it brought me so much joy and then you
would come on the show you guys came
together uh you came separately but you
came on the show and you would do bits
uh and we would talk and it was just a
thrill because I think uh sketch comedy
is an underrated art and the re it's
it's so seldom that I see sketch comedy
performers that I think are just
magnificent and you guys came along and
just killed it right away was I mean
some of the sketches I I've spent years
relating them to people like you know
that one you know that one um there's
the
the the burn victim in the insult comic
that one
a lot of comedians really connect with
this one yes yes and I I mean to that
one I mean there's so many great
sketches but but that one I have talked
about with other other comics and other
people other non-comics and said do you
know this sketch and uh comedian insult
comedian going around the audience and
then respectfully passes over someone
who clearly has been in a horrible
situation Burns all over them and is
just but passes over tries to start
heckling and uh you know doing crowd
work with the next guy and the guy goes
do
me and he says and he says no no no sir
I I wouldn't you say I can take
it and you make him do it and then he
does it and you're like too
far I thought I could take it but I
can't yeah I I was crying when I first
saw that I've watched it m multiple
times and you guys have many sketches
like that but I was like okay that's up
there with you know take your favorite
satv pieces take your favorite uh you
know your favorite sketch from SNL ever
take your favorite uh you know uh you
name it um uh uh Monty Python I mean
just the whole Pantheon you guys have a
bunch of sketches that slide in there
and God godamn it they amazing believe
Alex Rubin was the writer on that sketch
as well and we had an amazing team of
writers so if I'm wrong about that I'm
desperately mortified but look I uh but
also the commitment it's the it's the
ideas and then the
performances
uh simplest idea in the world with the
Black Panther leader oh yeah Keegan is
is their Black Panther leader and he's
talking really angrily and you're just
making this kind of defiant face in the
background and then you start popping up
into the foreground and then you come in
from the side and then you come in from
the top which is just insane and you
know I I was uh raised on Warner
Brothers cartoons and my sense of humor
has always been very cartoonish and when
you guys would go into that cartoon
world where reality bends in this
beautiful way
to to frustrate the expectation I was
just over the moon thank you look I have
to and I have to bounce that right back
at you so much of this I mean so much of
this is born from your your work um and
your your heightening your sort of
textbook the The Simpsons this you know
and and it was a type of sketch comedy
that you see in the best sketches where
it's just kind of an aggressive and
ridiculous lightning and Mr show did it
you know um and so we were just like
okay we have this opportunity to do this
thing yeah and then I'm you know one of
the reasons I've always you know I've
chatted with you we've talked but I've
always thought okay if I get you in this
format because you know um I've I've
spoken uh to Keegan and I'm Al like
you're here and I want to know like
where do I always want to find
out where do where do these Minds come
from where does this come from and so I
I kind of want to just talk about you
growing up in New York at what point do
you
realize I I think of very strange things
and really like comedy or was was your
first true love film or was it comedy or
both or horror where does it where does
it all start I probably fell in love
with comedy at the same time I was
getting really scared by and I mean
scared like in the as a kid like you
know kid growing up in New York I grew
up NE next to a a building called the
statford arms that was a a a hotel for
transients is what it said on the and it
was basically it was you know PE very
interesting characters let's just put it
that way and so I had a very uh blessed
Upper West Side you know upbringing that
was you know was cultured and that that
whole privilege but it was also it's
just like there's a creepiness to it as
well so those two things I think
developed side by side but at some point
they collided for me yeah and they did
in in film yeah so you start what are
the movies that you're watching that
terrify you when you're a kid well so
you know if I'm first thing out of my
gate this a lot of people would say but
Nightmare on Elm Street was that that
imagery for for my
for my specific generation that was like
too young when that came out or or Too
Young it was like it was more seeing the
the posters and the and the thing that
it just evoked such Terror yeah and so
that was form that's a formative boogy
man but then falling in love with Cinema
and stuff it's like stuff like The
Shining I know you've you've referenced
Rosemary's
Baby and what I see in in that
film that I think the best
directors uh try you know try to harness
or a similar feel is slowly turning the
dial you know because I always loved
about Rosemary's Baby and you can relate
to this cuz it filmed you know takes
place in the Dakota upper White upper
wests side blocks from where you mhm
grew up and something's it starts out
and everything's fine and it's the
slowly turning of the knob where things
are less and less fine but it's hard to
identify the exact moment when things is
that is does that bring true for you I
love that style and I love that location
I do have this real Nostalgia and
connection with that of course that's
where John Lennon was shot and so there
there's uh there's all sorts of uh
connotations right with that area um
that are so uh dark but I also think
that's such a big part of the horror
kind of with with comedy is the
grounding character you know the person
that ropes Us in and
reacts and it's you know with
horror it's it's the toad in the in the
pot Theory right if you if you throw a
toad into a boiling pot then that
person's going to walk leave the scene
that character needs to get out of there
right and that's a you don't want that
as a horror film you got to keep them in
this isolated spot so you slowly turn up
the heat on the character yeah the idea
being that toad gets in it's like
lukewarm kind of feels okay and the
temperature slowly Rising things are
getting more and more uncomfortable and
you can kind of believe why the
character would convince themselves oh
well maybe it's just me you know it's so
it's so interesting cuz there's like a I
haven't thought about this at all but
there
are their
close brothers or they're they're
related comedy and horror there's a
similar thing going on it's just because
you need to acclimate somebody to
something that's very normal and my
favorite comedies are let's acclimate to
something very normal and then you
slowly start to bend things and twist
things of course you get to this insane
place but a lot of comedies that are
most effective work that way they get
you to buy into a reality and then uh
you then you have to start accepting a
few premises here and there along the
way but you get sort of spoonfed them
and I think it's the same thing with
probably really good horror or the kind
of horror I respond to yeah and and and
just like the comedy it's like the the
heightening the pushing the fan the the
Fantastical in the
imagination um that becomes a certain
type of um project and
exercise but the exercise of grounding
it is always what makes it work you know
it's it's it's uh and and that to me in
horror especially is the is the hardest
part because you know how do you gr how
do you ground this idea that your
protagonist
uh would would uh stay in this situation
very long kind of always comes up how
can they not solve this and you're
you're you're putting the audience in
this angst of wanting your character to
solve it but you're not giving that to
them and so the only way way to make
that in any way satisfying is to kind of
like honor the the the the grounded
experience as as much as possible it's
interesting because uh I was thinking of
you know when
you uh when you did get
out it's very important
that as you said if if someone shows up
goes away for a weekend with his
girlfriend and goes to a house meet the
family if things are up right
away they're out the door so you you
have all these reasons which I can
relate to which is no no this is okay
this is all right I'm going to stay here
I'm going to stay in this okay I can
handle this and then things you you can
like you say turn up the heat on the pot
but how you do it and how gradually you
do it is really important and that's the
the guest Who's Coming to Dinner setup
is one that everyone kind of like
connects to which is
like that anxiety of meeting your
in-laws for the first time your
potential in-laws and you want to crawl
out of your skin and leave but you can't
you're there for reason so we we
all I just left too there's like what's
that line in there and trying to
uh the who is it um the terrific actor
oh Bradley Whitford yeah Bradley
Whitford is it Bradley Whitford who says
oh man Obama hey great greatest
president right and and you just think
okay this is I I would have voted for
him a third
time but I was just thinking like to me
that's also a funny comedy situation too
which is this white person is way over
is is pushing it do you know what I mean
like well yeah that that that was
that was the element of and I'm sorry I
said that to you when you came in today
well yeah well that you should Obama man
right Little Tone it was it was Little
Tone de there's just such a thing as
being two color
blind you
don't I'm sorry I you I was trying to I
was trying to get in good with you right
away and it was weird good you know we
know each other yeah but then I was
saying he should be a Supreme Court
Justice and you said let's Let It Go I I
don't need yeah I don't you know I don't
need to be cast as your
judge I don't need to be I don't need to
be president of the United
States no but look I mean we're
obviously J but it's it's um this and
you know it is in it in its Essence it's
kind of a key and peel sketch it's an
observation of being black in white
spaces and in that time I don't remember
it having sort of been uh said like that
and so I I remember just writing that
and feeling like it was the moment I
realized I had to direct the film that I
was writing because I was like I don't I
don't know anybody who can do that who
can direct that that's a big that's a a
big leap because yes okay you write this
screenplay obviously terrific
screenplay and you're a known
quantity uh writer performer and then
you say I'd like to direct this
how was what was the reaction you know
it was
surprisingly okay yeah um to this is sha
mckitrick to this this guy at QC
entertainment I was pitching to by the
way I pitched it like no no one's ever
going to do this movie but here's the
pitch and and pitched you know this
crazy plot and um started writing it
about a couple uh months into writing it
and again I knew the whole thing but a
couple months into the writing and I
realized made this call and he said go
go for it and it's Bas it's just like a
$5 million movie so it wasn't like you
know it was like kind of the perfect
type of RIS a part of it was we can't
afford anyone else you know what I mean
this is like micro budget I'll I'll
direct it and I'll I'll be you can pay
me $6 I thought it would be more
controversial but he said yes way too
quick I was like well let's negotiate
tried to back check too
late